This element is unique in the periodic table
- element 117, Uus, because
it’s never been observed in any form at
all.
On the 5th of April, which is just a few days
ago, there was a really,
really quite key paper accepted into a physics
journal. This essentially
told us that some folk in Russia in Dubna
had managed to make a new
element. Here on my computer screen let’s
bring up the periodic table.
So this is the periodic table as we know it.
All of the groups, all of the
periods, right the way down to number 118.
There is only one element
which isn’t coloured, ok, so it doesn’t
belong to an s, p, d or f block. It
hasn’t been identified. And that’s element
number 117. So this paper
which is published by the folk from the Joint
Institute For Nuclear
Research in Dubna claim to have produced a
small number of atoms of
element number 117. No no, it’s really exciting
because it’s the
generation of new matter. It’s almost like
a chill goes up your spine
that’s like “wow, something new, something
really exciting.” It’s almost
akin to the announcement of Nobel Prizes,
a celebration of good science.
So yeah it’s a really exciting time.
The element 117 is a synthetic element. What
this means is that it’s not
stable or that it’s not found naturally
on the planet, ok. So all of the
elements with an atomic number greater than
that of uranium are non-
stable, they all decay or they undergo radioactive
decay processes; and
117 is one of these. Now if we were to study
the chemistry of any of
these higher or super-heavy elements, we actually
have to make them.
We have to make them using linear accelerators,
and very fast
accelerating technologies. Now you might remember
Martyn did a video
when he went to the linear accelerating facility
in Germany and he told
us a little bit about an analogy about how
you make these new atoms or
these new elements and his analogy was really
with snow. So he made a
snowball and he threw some snow, a snowball
at a tree or a target which
already had some snow on it, and the lump
of snow on the tree got
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger. So
what these guys have done
is they’ve taken a target, which in this
case is berkelium. It’s a synthetic
material which was made in the United States.
It took a tremendous
amount of effort to make this material in
itself, but that’s a completely
different story. And they took this berkelium
which incidentally has a
half-life of something in the order of 270
days I think, in fact no it’s 320
days the half-life of berkelium. So these
experiments had to be done
pretty quickly after the berkelium had been
made. This was then
transferred to the Russian group who formed
a target. So a target is a
bit like a CD or a disc, it’s nice and flat
and circular and it rotates inside a
beam. And that beam is really what the accelerator
does, because it
takes ions and, in this case, in the Dubna
case in Russia, these are
calcium ions, so these are calcium-20 with
lots and lots of neutrons, so
48-calcium, and it shoots a very fast beam
of these ions directly at the
target. Now they impact and hopefully they
undergo fusion and they
generate the new atom or the new element.
You might assume that these experiments might
take very long periods of
time and this is true, because the time taken
in Dubna was something in
the order of between 5 and 7 months to prepare
just 6 atoms of this new
material. So a quite fantastic effort and
quite a fantastic research
program involving world-leading scientists
from the Oak Ridge National
Laboratories and also the Dubna Laboratories
in Russia.
What’s going to happen with the name now
by the way?
Well, the name of the element, wow! That’s
a fantastic question isn’t it,
because it already has a Latin name: ununseptium
– 117, ok. And this
really is a place-holder in the periodic table.
So the process now is that
somebody has to verify these results, and
once the results have been
verified, an open discussion will be held
and that will be moderated by
IUPAC, International Union of Pure and Applied
Chemistry, in the same
way that a new name came up with copernicium
in the past. So, at the
moment, many people, especially those in Russia,
will start to use
Mendeleev’s naming convention for gaps in
the periodic table. And
Mendeleev would have called this material:
eka-astatine, because
astatine is the element above it in the periodic
table. I’m really not sure
who will actually give the name to this material
because this was a true
collaboration between world-renowned scientists
in both the United
States and also in Russia. So I dare say they’ll
have a ‘pow-wow’ round
the table and they’ll come up with a very
nice name.
This evidence or this kinetic evidence is
fantastic. Very, very good
supporting evidence for commonly held theories
of islands of stability
where new elements may well be discovered
with much, much higher
atomic mass. And these would be over and above
the recognised or the
accepted top value in our table of 118. The
new element 117 is an
interesting element and we can perhaps suggest
things about its
chemistry by looking at the periodic table.
So if we look at the periodic
table we can see that it sits quite happily
in a group which we know as
the halogens. So it sits below fluorine, chlorine,
bromine, iodine, and
astatine. So we know right away that it’s
going to want to form an anion.
It’s going to want to take an extra electron
from an electron donor. But
what will the element look like? Well in its
bulk form I would guess,
looking at the periodic table, it would be
metal or a metalloid and it
would probably be very dark and lustrous.
So it would be shiny but quite
dark. But we have to make more than 6.